Kyle being back up north you know always
and I got to have that red leaf man you
know you just can't get it in the States
through North Ryde was on full display
as Jim Carrey picked up a generation
award at the jfl Award gala in Montreal
and to say his fellow comedians were
fans of the insanely talented star well
that would be an understatement there's
nobody who deserves a comedy award more
than Jim Carrey I mean he's up there
with Steve Martin in which a Pryor in
Groucho Marx but it's exciting to just
be able to keep our life acting since he
was 19 jim has crossed over generations
of fans and his work well everyone has a
favorite probably the Matt I know it's
old school but that was one I was like
this dude is a genius okay I think for
me I can maybe The Truman Show actually
is very moving good morning oh and in
case I don't see you good afternoon good
evening and good night
Truman Show Truman Show and are you know
living color so I hear you folks like to
take shots at firemen fire marshal bill
is pretty good yeah so that was a crazy
one and yeah you're my age you grew up
they spent Arab means a very big deal
probably liar liar I love that will be
Jim Ted that was that was Jim Carrey
just being Jim Carrey I can't lie the
mosque was everything for me yeah I know
most people vote like ASA insurace about
the mosque was just I was yeah The Daily
Show host Trevor Noah also has a very
personal connection to Jim while
accepting his comedy Person of the Year
award he opened up about his struggles
with depression and how Jim's story of
getting off Prozac for his depression
help him I thank you because you know I
found a way spike I found a way to build
a community and that's what this place
is it's a community of people trying to
do sir